[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle mark s
et j'ai accepté de mon plein gré d'avoir
recours à une opération
de dissociation
je consens à séparer les souvenirs de ma
vie professionnelle
de ceux de ma vie personnelle
j'atteste avoir compris qu'une fois
l'opération terminée je n'aurai plus
accès à mes souvenirs personnels à les
tâches des dissocier dit gratitude pas
plus que je n'aurais de souvenirs
professionnels
désolé quand je rentrerai chez moi après
le travail
je fais cette déclaration sans
contrainte
[Musique]
vu les enfants on mange quoi ce soir tu
avais prévenu mon sens du quotidien vous
rigolez ans déteste on lui a donné
combien de raison valable 8 bonjour
bonjour monsieur messier marque vous
avez une minute titi ne fait plus partie
de cette entreprise je suis désolé
marque votre amitié entre collègues ou
touchait beaucoup qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on aimerait vous répondre mais
c'est interdit par notre petit on
suppute j'ai le plaisir de vous accorder
de servir en tant que chef du
département d'autres délits citation si
vous le désirez une poignée de main peut
vous être accordées je veux bien une
poignée de main dans ce cas
[Musique]
on s'est déjà vu je m'applique pythie je
bossais avec toi
donc on est amis je suis en meilleure
amie
y'a rien qui soit vraiment ce qu'ils
disent je me disais qu'il fallait être à
monstres pour envoyer quelqu'un
travailler là-bas et encore plus pour
scier envoyé soi même
tu veut se voir ce qui se passe là bas
tu y trouveras le début
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui marche
qu'est-ce qu'on fait exactement ici
enfin il faut que votre regard soit ou
es ce que vous avez faire un regard
[Musique]